I have amazing news. I think that when I
die, the thing that I will be most proud
of is not the businesses that I've
built, but the books that I've written.
Alex Mosy, 100 million dollar offers,
sold over 430,000 copies. I launched it
before I had an audience. I have been
working for 2 years on a single project
that launches on August 19th. Great
writing comes from a place of wanting to
add to the body of knowledge.
100 million leads is finally here. We're
launching it on August 19th at a live
event. I'm going to make this the Super
Bowl for entrepreneurship. I put a
million bucks into the event to make it
unbelievable for you guys and hopefully
there's a spoiler nation and go over the
top with the amount of things we've been
giving away. But it's only going to be
for people who are live there with me.
So, you're not going to miss it. Go to
the link acquisition.com/leads
and I will see you guys there. Invite
your friends.